since extending Taco Tuesdays to
Wednesday we have seen a 13% increase in
followers I see and we have some really
great promotions for August about August
we were thinking this might be a good
time to go with a new agency really
unless you've got something else that
you can show me no I mean it it seems
like your mind is made up
alright then bye so should I stop
working on taco shark week they were her
oldest client how do you do it Elliot
do what fail well you walk around with
your pants unbuttoned you can't get a
fortune out of a cookie so you eat the
whole thing no one can remember your
dumb name well I'm working on a new
nickname the ee dog or el trained all
your boss can do is lose clients it'll
be okay
what are you doing I thought you needed
a hug I don't like to be touched
oh yeah I forgot I'm sorry now I'll just
I'll just go maybe I should just go hey
why didn't you fight for it I mean we
had great ideas I know but I got nervous
the only time I'm not nervous is the
moment I wake up and I'm trying to
figure out if it's real life or a waking
nightmare actual confrontation is a
little different Elliot but you're the
boss I mean this is what you do what do
you know you let people walk all over
you but I'm not the boss here I am the
boss at home you live alone well mr.
Harrison Brittany purrs are my employees
no they're your cats my incredibly
well-behaved cats who can use a toilet
because I insisted on it hmm
I got an idea come with old l-train
summer can you get some coffee oh I'm
super busy right now but how about later
okay good bye
that's it you're the boss this is your
house
summer I need you to get me and Elliot
some coffee oh sure thing boss
see isn't this great
it's incredible I asked for something
and I got it mm-hmm
now for something a little more
challenging Bennett get up Wow it's 4:00
p.m. you have to go back to work five
minutes no right now because we do not
have siestas in this office I don't care
how many semesters you spent in
Barcelona I suppose no no no you're
unbearable drink this and go back to
your cubes fine thank you
I'm doing it I'm being the boss like a
cat who can use a toilet you are
unstoppable
you're right Elliot I want you to make a
dating profile oh no no no that this
isn't about me that this is about you
becoming the person you were meant to be
no I think this is about you expanding
your horizons beyond cat whoo [ __ ] like
people I mean I don't have any good
photos or favorite movie or cool Gandhi
quotes or oh okay no no no here I'll do
it if you call back Viva taquito mister
Chiquito
this is Natalie your company needs to
connect with local teens we are the only
social media company in the area that
can get the job done right with our
guidance we can push Taco Tuesday
straight through to Saturday
and God willing maybe even Sunday
excellent
so what did he say I got the machine it
did it I still don't like being touched
DeLeon oh yeah sorry
I hate you why turn 18 I'm moving out
you